you'll reject nation I'm Greg Elbe how
you doing and I'm John Humphrey yeah
we're gonna tuck it back three two hey
real in this movie but yeah I mean Greg
Alcazar at the jug don't make sense no
all right here we go
hi guys we saw Cretu last night Happy
Thanksgiving to all glad you're here
watching you should be with your
families but you're alone and I'm sorry
you know what I'm grateful for every
single person that has downloaded and
followed us on the Stardust app you're
the ones I'm really grateful for you see
over there with you 30 second reaction
reviews for films TV shows and trailers
a lot of them are micro sketches man am
i grateful to you guys if you want me to
be grateful to you you know what to do
it's free to use free to download doing
app let's talk about Creed - all right
so if you hear some like collarbone like
jangling around there's a dog I'm
watching right now that's sitting right
next to me at this very moment so uh
Cretu is about Adonis Creed having two
verse the son of the man who killed his
father in rocky for Ivan Drago killed
Apollo and now he's fighting Victor
Drago this was a movie I'm very much
looking forward to I was a huge fan of
the first Korean movie and I'm a major
major Rocky fan I don't think any of
them were my favorite movie of all time
it's also the French eyes I've actually
seen more than any other franchise I've
seen so many so many times so this film
I actually thought was really damn good
I liked it all hell of a lot I had a
great time watching it you did - yeah
there's a couple of things that I think
right away that I noticed improvements
on first off the first Creed is not
really about Adonis versing anyone there
is an antagonist sort of it really is a
sort of antagonist thing you know just a
guy who has to fight at the end but this
one it really is Victor Drago versus
Adonis Creed but it's also more than
that but with that element the way they
handle the villains of Ivan and Victor I
was especially surprised by with how
much intimacy you get with these guys
because you really get to understand
their dynamics you really get to
understand
their relationship they're not just
treated as though they're bad Russians
like rocky for against there are real
people and I really enjoyed their
performances and I was especially
surprised with how you can get kind of a
cheesy ass villain like Ivan Drago
Nawrocki for catch up with him decades
later then you get a really good
dramatic performance by Dolph London and
this one weirdly that whole aspect of
the movie and getting that little
glimpse into the Drago's as humans kind
of brought me back to Cobra Kai yeah
I've gotta make me want to see a version
of this words just like Rocky as a
trainer and Drago as a trainer and
seeing them media because Drago is a
very different guy now than when you
knew him in Rocky four as well and
that's part of what makes this so
compelling is it time is truly past and
they have a personal story even though
it doesn't take up anywhere near the
majority of the surround I'm you know it
was a pleasant surprise most definitely
it makes the fight personal absolutely
both Crede and Rocky because a lot of
the themes of this film there are pretty
in your face about it but it works that
you know the sins of the father are
passed down to the son that is the theme
of this whole film and it works it
really plays to that strength and
another major improvement I thought it
did is I liked Tessa Thompson and
Michael B Jordan in the first Creed I
don't I wasn't in love with them as a
couple or their chemistry but in this
movie it does pick up sometime after
treatments not like immediately after
there are history that's developed and
the way the relationship is formed and
maybe just as them as performers as well
because you know but having them in this
movie I really did fall in love with
them as a couple almost instantaneously
you can feel their chemistry is just
that much more dynamic they were really
lived in relationship and gay rights
it's even little mannerisms and just the
those little familiarities and I'm
really helped to sell it yeah I love
them together and I really feel like a
lot of the unique elements are come into
play in term or in terms of how their
relationship is handled and plot points
that occur within their family that's
stuff we haven't seen in any of the
other Rocky movies or this whole
franchise come and be honest this is
very formulaic film it's really
predictable for a fan of the franchise
that's not really an issue for me
because
most of them are predictable and will
they go the dance or not like I've said
it before there's movies I hate that are
so formulaic and offer nothing exciting
but then there's movies like the rocky
franchise which are very formulaic and
this movie is formulaic but it's
executed very well I think the
performances are so damn good I like
Michael B Jordan as Adonis is like just
as electrifying as ever and so
compelling
the first Creed movie feels like Adonis
Adonis Dantas is the damned ' Adonis
Creed's movie with rocky being the main
supporting character having a supporting
character storyline but in this movie
it's very much more Adonis's movie and
Rocky's there is there to support Adonit
he's not as prevalent in this movie
that's not a bad thing because this is
slowly handing off the entire franchise
to him yeah and I thought that was kind
of appropriate for this and appropriate
for the story too because they hone in
on the family element the fact that
Creed's family is basically Bianca rocky
and his mom you know yeah having rocky
more towards the background also adds a
narrative you know Foyle adds some
weight because you know a lot of this
movie is about Creed having to kind of
find it within himself and kind of get
to rock bottom on his own rock and it's
more of the role that Rocky's actually
playing in this movie not the attitude
of Vic but more the position making yeah
that tough but sage advice yeah for
these boxing movies for this franchise
you really got a root for your main
character as he goes on this journey I
do love Michael B Jordan as Adonis Creed
but especially in this movie I found
myself exceptionally rooting for this
guy to win the match I think in general
just because of the type of movie it is
is predictable but I think especially if
you're a fan of the franchise it's
especially predictable and I don't want
to make that sound like it takes away
from me enjoying it there were parts
that were a little bit of a detriment to
that because this film borrows heavily
from not just rocky for obviously in a
lot of ways this feels like it could
have been a direct sequel to rocky for
oh yeah they're more robots yeah it
borrows a lot of plot beats a lot of
plot points from Rocky 3 especially and
it borrows a lot of how appalled
attitude is in rocky - man is dangerous
man what's the marriage angle and things
like that
yeah there's rocky two three and four
rocky two's my favorite Rocky movie I
don't think it's the best one but it's
my personal favorite Rocky three and
four is when it gets exceptionally corny
and really cheesy and then completely
falls apart by the time you get to Rocky
five Rocky 4 is my favorite and I do
think it's the best so what was
interesting about this was even though
this is more Creed's movie than Rocky's
and even though its borrowing plot
points like the beats of Rocky three
especially which are very corny films
this is like the more dark serious
version of those movie somehow avoided
being corny somehow yeah still had the
same plot points because this movie is
very dark it's a much more serious film
than any of the films in this French I
like Creed's a pretty serious film it
still has a lot of charm it still has a
lot of that spirit this movie I feel
like that might have been a bit of a
missing element for me as a fan of just
the franchise is I miss some of that
charm because they're really laughs
during this movie another you're walking
this movie laughing upbeat heart spirit
vibe that is not really in here
throughout it's a very dark film and
occasionally it's borderline
melodramatic in terms of like soap opera
territory that's very minimal though I
think for the most part majority of this
the drama really works the darkness
really works yeah it's just is more the
volume of like serious life
circumstances that he's faced to go of
course this movie that kind of flirts
with that there are little moments of
levity but I almost feel like they're
they're like buttons on the ends of
certain scenes so it's like you'll get a
chuckle once every 20 minutes maybe but
yeah it isn't much darker movie too
heavy because it's so personal and the
stakes are so much higher because
there's always that looming element of
death ya know it's like if he fights
this guy is he gonna die because you
know Donnie doesn't want to give up and
is not gonna want to throw in that towel
yeah which is the whole big issue about
the fight with his father in the first
place in terms of direction because this
is not Ryan Coogler returning I think
Steven Capel jr. did a pretty good job
like and I think part of my experience
was effected is I don't
a harp on this too much because I sought
a theater where it was obvious that the
projection was just not on par like it
was so apparently this is ridiculously
dark and I know this don't limp that
drives those experiences really just
know there's something wrong with the
screen and I think the fight scenes are
really good in this movie I think the
boxing matches are great if I were to
take a step back and compare it I don't
think they're as well-constructed as
Ryan Coogler Direction no no I can't say
that Ryan Coogler had a much more
confident hand and was better at
dramatizing the story elements of the
fights if I don't really not afraid it
it's like there there's something about
the way the the story of the fights
unfolds in creed one that I find a
little bit more effective there than I
do here but if I don't compare it even
with comparison though it's still great
fight scenes like they're super like
these are really getting into it like
it's still really intense yeah I mean
definitely the fights are still really
thrilling and they're really well
captured I will meet you there though
and say that the first movie I never
really fell out of it you know whereas
at times during this one I would catch
myself going oh yeah this is a bit
familiar or whatever so it wasn't quite
as consistent to the point where I just
never got hold out of it if that makes
yeah well I think it's not only on
Stephen capable jr. I think also it's
also on the fact that you know it's like
Stallone did come back to write this one
I appreciate him not you know making
himself front and center for this movie
even though he like he I think he's like
the co-writer but then I'm like yeah it
also makes sense why this feels more
like the rocky sequels then Creed felt
like that's what I mean by sometimes the
melodramatic elements can feel a little
bit soap opera because sometimes
Stallone gets a little bit preachy and a
little bit on the nose without we handle
certain scenes but that's very minimal I
think most of this is really effective
really good even though it's formulaic I
still had a great time and I still think
a lot of the emotional beats really hit
home and there's improvements on the
villainy and also on the dynamics we
tested Thompson I could be drawn which
is very crucial to this story working
while there's some stuff that's missing
in terms of Ryan cooler's direction I
still think there's actually
improvements from the first one you kind
of get a little bit about great first
impression for Steven capable junior for
sure and any complaints I have
ultimately amount to things that are
familiar in the script that make it a
little less
chanting of a story because this isn't
as new to us now the whole drago rematch
could have been so silly and i thought
they handled that really well and for
all the things this movie has to do
arguably that's the most important one
and that's the most cathartic and
engaging part of the movie like I
actually wanted more with the Drago's
honestly yeah it's crazy how there's
three movies in a row this franchise
where every time I hear what they're
doing I'm like how can this work yeah
you know like Rocky Balboa he's so old
how could then it's great Creed what
you're making a supporting character
what do I care about Apollo Creed son
Wow so good then this one - you're like
that sounds so stupid and cheesy and
then you watch you're like wow this is
really work so you know yeah every time
it's it's a nice surprise at how well
they still pull these movies off I
really do recommend it and I had a great
time watching it oh my god sikri - did
you like it do you prefer it over the
first one where do you think this movie
can go is there a room for more sequels
what's your favorite Rocky movie choose
one of the questions subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
balland download a false in the Stardust
app today people Happy Thanksgiving